une surprise une surprise à
22h11 ça continue le prime des années 90
j'espère que vous passer un bon moment
avec
nous
[Musique]
sonnerie ça
ça allô allô sal c'est Diego
oui qui est à la Paris bonsoir alors
c'est quelqu'un déjà qui sort d'un
accident apparemment c'est quel'un qui a
pas qui a pas toute sa patate bonsoir
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un premier
indice sur la personne qui est concernée
par cette surprise premier indice
j'aurais pu faire partie de la famille
d'une personne présente sur votre
plateau ah ilaurait pu faire partir
alors ça peut être bah ça peut être tout
le monde hein ça peut être tout le monde
est-ce qu'on peut avoir un autre
indice cette personne était folle
amoureuse de mon grand oncle ah ah ah ah
donc déjà c'est c'est Daniel alors non
non attendez attendez attendez attendez
attendez attendez est-ce que est-ce que
s'il vous plaît est-ce que s'il vous
plaît est-ce que s'il vous plaît est-ce
qu'on peut avoir une photo de votre
grand tong s'il vous plaît est-ce qu'on
peut mettre une photo du Grand
tong attendez
attendez
attendez vous êtes donc vous êtes donc
le petit fils de Jean lepoulin l'arrière
Petitfils le neveu le neveu excuse-moi
oui vous êtes le neveu de Jean lepoulin
incroable et vous êtes venu faire une
surprise à Daniel ce soir c'est ça le
neveu de Jean Le
[Applaudissements]
Poulin
attends il
ressemble qu' son comment vous appelez
George George le Poulin George le
Poulin
il attends le condne pas comme ça
dans passer un truc ou merci merci
George le Poulin c'est une CAD c'est
bien sûr cétait une
rigolens bien sû c'est faux c'est fa
c'est une rigol cétait juste pour la rig
rapide parce qu'on a on a une vraie
surprise pour toi Danieli à côté de
Daniel George le
pou George s'appelle comment du coup s'
com tu s'appelle George en vrai
Jérôme les chér on a on a vraiment une
surprise pour
Daniel vraiment une surprise pour
Daniel mais ça n'arrête pas ce soir
standard mais sans
déconnerë
[Rires]
uneore allô
allô VO bonsoir bonsoir alors on on sait
que a priori vous êtes une surprise pour
Daniel ben
j'espère sans une voix est-ce qu'on peut
avoir déjà un premier indice qui a vécu
euh j'ai travaillé pendant 2 ans avec
Daniel ah oui oui ah ahah il y en a
beaucoup qui ont travaillé pendant 2 an
avec est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on a un
autre indice un autre
indice c'est présenteux mais j'étais son
fantasme oh oh ah oui est-ce que vous
avez un
[Rires]
strabisme c'est possible vous étiez le
fantasme de Daniel et vous avez
travaillé 2 ans avec elle on a un trè
indice euh oui
elle va tout de suite m'identifier ah si
je le dis allez-y
elle me surnommé is no good non Léon
citrone non est-ce que tu vois de qui il
s'agit mais quelle
horreur merci pour moi
attends
attends c'est Affre mais je vois je sais
je sais que surnommé quelqu'un ISN mais
là c c'était ton fantasme
ou merde je sa plus est-ce que vous
pouvezz c'est quand j'étais assistante
alors bah est-ce que vous voyez de qui
s'agitante de qui c'était c'était sur
une émission de de Jean Bardin c'était
cette
é les
blion
pardon tu le prenais tu le prenais en
photo en secret ah c'est grave du
harcèlement on à l'épreuve Daniel non
mais montrez pas tout de suite la Testas
du Gar ah bah oui alors non c'est des
paroles d'expert c'est ça parole
d'expert oui c'est ça oui ou ça et vous
aimez vous aimez les les vieilles
choses j'aime j'aime tout les Bones
choses bon chos les vieilles choses les
belles les belles choses les belles les
vieilles et belles choses Bell chos vous
êtes donc
antiire pas tout à c'est est-ce que
pouvez nous donner le nom alors je pense
est-ce que vous vous appelez pierre oui
pierre pierre ah oui c'est vrai oui'is
pierre pierre Daniel c'était ton
fantasme pierre pierre il sera avec nous
dans un instant on a hâte de voir la
ganage du gars ça va toi ouis bah ça va
aller encore mieux puisque on a le crush
de Daniel ouais V c vraiment ça Daniel
c'est quand même un jour un croch hein
et euh Daniel Daniel est-ce que tu peux
nous raconter un petit peu avant qu'on
accueille Jean il s'appelle Jean non
pierre
pierre j'ai pas toutes les infos est-ce
que avant qu'on accueille Pierre
Jean Jean-Pierre
Jean-Pierre est-ce que tu peux nous dire
c'est quoi le bail avec lui bah en fait
donc j'étais juste assistante sur une
émission qui s'appelait parole d'expert
sur France 3 et il y avait plein de
chroniqueurs et lui était chroniqueurs
objet et c'est vrai que c'était l'objet
just l'objet de mes fantas viens non
mais c'est pas Jean Le Poulin là c'est
un beau gosse attention je viens de voir
la tau bah écoutez là ou là ou e ça
surprend bon délire est-ce que vous
voulez qu'il vienne ce soir bah
j'adorerais je pas revu depu on vair est
célibatair c'est c'est Pierre Blanché
ouais oh c'est
sero on est peut-être un tournant
sentimental ah oui oui
la nouvelle année peut-être un tournant
sentimental voy il est avec nous Pier
blanch est avec
[Applaudissements]
nous
toujour ou
vasy que du
bonheur que du bonheur alors pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont travaillé ensemble dans
les années 90 c'est un années 90 c'est
pas n'importe quoi ce prime voil pas DEP
20 on compte pas quand on il est
toujours beau oui pas commeant ah si si
tu es beau ah non tu es tu es beau gosse
j rapport le Poulin ah ouais tu gag
surtout maintenant vachement c'est le
Poulin maintenant c'est pas
ouf le Poulin maintenant c'est pasors
ah ouais ah ouais ah ouais vend c'est
des photos que je prenais quoi ah ouais
tu l'as vendu la
chemise et elle avait et euh ça c'est à
Disney on AV à DISY je peux dire un truc
je peux te dire un truc je trouve encore
plus beau gosse maintenant je jure que
c'est
vrai mais je connais pas ces photos la
question qu'on se pose tous on s'en fout
des photos
làra question euh il y a une question
qu'on se pose ouais question que les
téléspectateurs se POS 2 que seose que
jeanmich il pas il a pas de
Ba professionnel iltre enlevé
justeant ba c'est bon
signe mal bon
just faisons pas sur la
comète la question qu'on se pose tous
j'aimerais une musique
de donc là ils sont en train de taper
musique de
suspens on fait voter les
téléspectateurs ah voilà voilà pierre il
est
22h25 nous sommes le 20
décembre je tiens à dire d'ailleurs aux
téléspectateurs qu'on sera demain en
direct bien sûr dans TPMP et vendredi on
sera là également c'est pas parce qu'on
fait le prime ce soir que c'est les
vacances ce soir les vacances arriveront
à point
nommé Pierre
euh tu es franchement je te trouve
beau gosse sympathique j'ai un bon
feeling sympathique
j'ai un bon
feeling quand je vous vois tous les deux
comme ça j'ai qu'une envie c'est de vous
voir faire
[Applaudissements]
l'amour gag
temps j'ai fa dire nu dans un lit
c'était pas obligatoirement pour faire
l'amour mais c'est vrai que je vous
voyais ah ouais en train Decher de trier
des
[Rires]
papiers pierre ou oui cy est-ce que vous
habitez la région parisienne oui à côté
d' oui donc elle peut faire des chic
Chac dans la journée oui je sais pas
elle travaille beaucoup pour vous non
temmerde pas libér je peux la libér ça
ça se libère très vite ça c'est pas dans
les
effecs pas le voir tout de
suite est-ce que
oui tu te verrais alors d'abord première
question est-ce que tu es célibataire
[Applaudissements]
oui je la
glue est-ce que est-ce que tu es
sébataire oui oui vent depuis longtemps
GL un certain
temps est-ce qu'au niveau de l'âge ça
corespou est pas trop jeune pas trop
jeune parce qu' est un peu jeune par que
il y a quand même des souvenirs de voilà
voilà il a pasux que je te dise si tu
pêches au pierre ah ouais franchement
belle c'est une
per c'est une perf c'est une perf mais
toi ai tu es très belle
je trouve en
plusir allez très bien ensemble très
bien
ensemble harmonieux Danel est-ce que
Pierre teî ah toujours autant
[Applaudissements]
ouais je connais je connais ça sent la
galoche ça sent
bon la voyante l'avait dit Pierre est-ce
que euh àce qu'un moment tu t'es dit
est-ce que c'est peut-être pas Daniel la
la buf qu'il me faut alors a les EM non
mais ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
s'est pas vu ouis à l'époque on était
très proche il jamais rien nu mais très
proche ça ça on regarde que nous oh
c'était du temps de parole d'expert
ouis ah ouais à mon avis
tout elle a garder un jardin secret
visiblement pas bon non non mais il y
avait a voilà il y a eu des
rapprochements on va dire les gars
attendssendsends on va s'arrêter de
petites secondes parce
que des travaux d'approche mais c'est
comme avec Hidalgo ça s'est arrêté aux
travaux d'approche on pas pas fini le
chantier quoi on n pas fini le CH on
dire il mis un casque quand
même aujourdhui je question d'abord à
toi est-ce que tu te verrais euh tenter
une histoire avec le beau Pier mais en
fait on a tellement ri je sais pas je
sais pas si on rirait pas en
faisantamour en fait je sais pas Mar oui
non c'est pas bien c'est pas un bon
signe non mais moi pour moi il a pas
changé et j'ai rien que pour ça je
t'adore le croch n'a pas
changé toi attends si tu es un mec tu
kiffes tu le kiffes physiquement tu
rigoles avec lui ou franchement il a
l'air d'avoir une
[Rires]
magnifique
j'aiuse mais
franchement pas mais franchement il il C
beaucoup
de ah ouais ouais al attendez déjà
nallons pas trop vite du côté de Daniel
c'est oui
ou c'est un
oui pour mettre papa dans
maman faut que deux personnes
soit pire il l'a pas fait pierre est-ce
que toi tu te verrais tenter une
histoire avec Daniel bah pourquoi
pas
but ou c'est
ou donc moi je vous dis pierre tu sais
quoi j'ai un coup de cœur pour toi
écoute c'est réciproque ah non je te j
j'ai un vrai coup de cœur pour toi non
mais vraiment la voix et tout j'adore je
trouve bien a un truc il s'intègre bien
à nous si tu t'intègres aussi bien à
l'équipe qui a la culotte de
dan
franchement ah mais je te le diserre je
te le dis pierre je te le dis je te dis
pierre merci de l' comme ça'ill on est
comme ça je vais te dire je peux Pier
Daniel pierre et Daniel d'accord je va
vous demander que de vous
galocher qui dit
ça ma
coimatrice elle sait ce que je vais dire
avant
de vouis
voulez non mais vous pensez la même
chose oui non mais sur la galoche oui on
pense la même chose oui je v vous
demander de venir au
centre je demandé de venir au centre de
la scène au centre de la scène
Arve il est ttanisé il est
tétanisé j'aimerais que vous mettiez
tous les deux comme ça tous les deux
comme ça prenez-vous la main dans la
main la main dans la main et s'il vous
plaît je vais vous
demander c'est très simple il y a vous
allez dire vous allez devoir dire un mot
en même temps tous les deux en vous
tenant la main en vous regardant droit
dans les bien ça le mot suicide il y a
trois il dit suicide ce
bâtard il y a tro il y a trois pistes il
y a il y a trois pistes ou bien la
première piste
c'est non on le sent pas c'est pas le
moment c'est pas le moment et donc le
pas envie de se galoche donc ça vous
direz dommage vous
direzoun ça c'est
pas si vous avez envie juste de vous
faire un smack vous
direz
SP ça fait un peu cocktail Tinqui pas et
si vous avez envie de vous galoche vous
dire en même temps
zB ridicule
atttion
pous ensemble il faut qu'on dis dire en
même temps si vous dites la même chose
s'il vous plaît on ne se concerte pas
vous n'entendez ma voix rien que ma voix
vos paupières sont
lourdes à 3 vous direz jepoun zbll
Oub on espère tous
[Rires]
unb qui a envie que c'est un
B
elle Aich
[Applaudissements]
Z plaî on y
va TR Pr
attendez oui je peux me permettre alors
c'est comme dans un mariage si quelqu'un
veut parler quelqu'un une objection
qu'il parle maintenant ou qu'il se ta à
tout jamais à tout jamais qui a-t-il
V alors j'ai hésité jusqu'à la dernière
minute et je me suis dit est-ce que je
dis est-ce que je dis pas mais comme on
est honnête non attendez attendez ce
c'estèsve diti dans l'oreille
d'abord
oh il réfléchit oh là oh merde objection
Kelly prenez vos responsabilités et
dites ce que vous avez vu ah ouais
carrément vu tuas vu alors j'ai vu je
viens de le dire à Jacques et il m'a dit
oui
balance il y a eu triche c'estàdire il y
concertation pendant que vous parliez
vous avez le de tourné ah et Daniel a
triché et j'ai peur que monsieur ne soit
pas du même AVI que Daniel alors
j'aimerais Danny que tu laisses le
monsieur dire ce qu'il a envie de dire
d'accord elle est pas elle est pas là
pour rigoler
elle sur la tte de ma mère jeai jamais
vu comme ça on dirait qu'elle joue sa
vie laès sux elle joue elle
joue Dani na pas tch c'est moi c'est moi
qui lui qui me sou pas des
m je demand c'est vrai c'est vrai
je don ceais passe dans votre oreille
remettez vos main dans la main redonner
les noms aussi parce
que c'est la galoche c'est vas-y ça se
galoche
bamamam voilà et on y va et vas-y et du
covid et tout
ça ils vont se covider tout ça j'adore
demain il son é mon
frère voilà voilà voilà demain demain
c'est vrai demain ils sont sous sont
sous antibiotiques
Z alors les
gars je vous dis moi ce que j'aurais
aimé maintenant vous faites ce que vous
voulez c'est pas mal aussi je vais
compter jusquà
[Rires]
allez je vais compter jusqu'à alors
mundir me suggère de compter jusqu'à
3 merci mundir de ton concours et de ta
participation à ce prime la télé il
connait la télé on lui fait
[Applaudissements]
pas
pas s du
tout de suite il va faut compter jusqu'à
3 c'est c'est pas 4 c'est pas c'est pas
10 quand tu il faut que ça PUL pas jeis
compter jusqu'à
5 dire c'est pas pour te faire chier
mais ah là là je vais aller de 5 à Z0
ok 5 4 3 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui
VI je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pasevoir
ou
[Applaudissements]
les gars les gars les gars est-ce qu'on
peut
remettre les gars les gars les gars pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent c'est une
soirée
historique c'est une soirée historique
historique et un beau gosse en plus
alors mais lui je l'adore pierre je
t'adore je te jure je me demande s'il
faut pas que tu viennes un peu nous voir
toi dans l'émission bien
vient dire quelque chose d'assz étonnant
et c'est vrai en le regardantem Michel
Dr tout le
temps je peux
[Rires]
plus rais de
profvie de Vivement
Dimanche attendez attendez les gars
est-ce qu'on peut revoir la scène est-ce
qu'on peut caler la scène est-ce qu'on
peut caler la scène 20 secondes avant
que ça se passe tu veux juste voir ma té
parce que même moi j'étais pas prêt sans
déconner j'étais pas prêt je suis CCH
personne nétait prêt je suis CCH
regardez sur ta
tête oh mon
[Rires]
dieuour et tout je m'attendais pas ça
m'endais à
tout
z reste avec nous reste ave nous reste a
nous pierre que tu viennes nous
BO les gars j'ai une
idée tu veux pas essayer d'être un peu
avec nous dans l'émission ah mais je
demande que ça
moi les gar on esté
là gars émotion int là qu'estce que vous
me faites là sans déconner les gars je
vi sortir de la la game BO qui le
téléphone frère vous voulez que je meure
ou quoi sans
décon tu vas faire l'émission avec nous
mais je demande que ça je te jure trs
bonveous il était chroniqueur objet
spécialist des objet non non mais dans
dans parole d'expert il éit chronqueur
objet il est commissaire
prise attach de PR non mais c'est c'est
important que tu sois avec ta
meuf
non mais je te jure sans déconner tu
viens à partir de janvier tu viens B
quand tu veux même demain peut-être
demain ou après-demain bah quand tu veux
problème il faudra qu'on par
l'argent m'a pris 300
[Applaudissements]
balles pas un garçon
intéressé la vérité voilà quelqu'un
voilà quelqu'un qui va faire une longue
carrière à mes
côtés
je l'adore